for some of you it probably seemed like
this day would never come
maybe you're even wondering if you're
ready for this
[Music]
for what comes next
you have no idea what I'm capable of
I didn't know who he was
I don't fight France because I would win
never apologize for saving lives there's
only one way this kid goes back out
there and that's on a very short leash
I'm just happy helping people
[Applause]
people try to kill us every single day
right I don't care how old he is he
needs to go
maybe if you train more and complained
less we could get back to saving lives
make them pay for what he did to your
world welcome son of he who slayed my
husband damn a normal human superhero I
wish he was dead too but not for your
sake kill fast and ask questions later
oh yeah
beltramide against viltromite that has
not happened since the Great Purge
[Music]
you should have died at Birth
foreign